ready for this yes sir
you will keel
the dahome machete my name is Adam
coonrod and I'm a firefighter paramedic
in the city Troy New York my wife and my
kids are very supportive and like that I
do knife making my two children they're
both makers as well and I couldn't be
any prouder of both of them
this lethal machete was once wielded by
the legendary all-female Army in Western
Africa known as the dahome Amazons the
long slightly curved blade flared out to
a wide tip giving the female warriors
the ability to deliver fatal blows that
cut clean through bone and flesh in a
single blow these skilled women warriors
were an elite fighting force and
extremely intimidating often carrying
trophies of their fallen enemies the
machetes were a powerful weapon designed
to cleave through anything that got in
their way today the dehome machete can
be seen wielded in the 2020 HBO series
Lovecraft country
I've been making blades for 14 years now
I just got my journeyman Smith stamp
it's a rating in the American blade
Smith Society it means you have reached
a certain level of quality in your work
the boazande sword hails from central
Africa and the tribes of the Congo
the short sword was used not only to
wage war but also as a ritual object and
status symbol
the more ornate the sword The Higher One
stature and Authority within the tribe
typically African blades have wildly
varying specifications and shapes and
this sword is no different it has a thin
ricasso that flares wide to a leaf shape
from there it tapers to a devastatingly
sharp Point that's built to make Extreme
Cuts and deep thrusts into the flesh
making the weapon a feared ambitious
killer
day one of my home Forge time to get
started I have never made anything this
big before if I win I'm going to
Disneyland
I think right now my biggest obstacle is
the size of the piece this piece of
metal is so thick and so large it's
taking forever to heat up just not
moving I'm growing impatient I think
there's enough steel here I actually cut
off a piece it's starting to move but
very nervous about how thin this blade
actually is starting to become I don't
want it to break or shatter really hope
it's not too thin pitter patter let's
get at her I got a little bit more
forging to do today starting to realize
how thin this blade actually is starting
to become I'm getting very nervous about
it I go to grind it a little bit and
the blade snaps
[Music]
I just threw out a whole bag I put some
pressure on it with the angle grinder
ended up doing too much pressure and it
broke my heart sinks I think I can fix
it because I don't want to start over I
have to fill that in with weld I can't
really tell anymore where that crack is
I start grinding about it a little bit
a whole bunch of cracks final day Make
It or Break It so yesterday I definitely
made to come back it's time to assemble
and I start working on my actual
physical handle I just don't want to use
a piece of wood I want to dress it up a
little bit so I twist three different
strands of wire so it's going to have an
alternating pattern the handle is
looking great it's better than I
imagined my kids came downstairs to
check on me how's the machete coming out
oh that's really cool you like that yeah
I can tell we're proud of me sticking it
through and being able to produce a
tangible item it's a proud dad moment
[Music]
given the ceremonial aesthetic aspect of
the boson day I'm gonna lean more
towards doing something flashy so I'm
gonna go with Damascus I cut in a ladder
pattern with a grinder and gotta get
ready to start shaping the blood after I
get in the tip kind of where I want it I
can start working down the blade pulling
that width out
everything looks awesome it's nice and
straight we're gonna let it cool off
here and I'm gonna work on my handle and
fittings if I decide to go ahead and do
a ladder pattern on the guard plate and
pommel plate because I figure it'll be
kind of complementary to the sword blade
I'm making the handle out of Rosewood
which is native to Africa so it would be
relatively historically accurate let's
go see if it'll cut anything
you know I'm pretty confident that this
thing will handle anything that they can
throw at it
do
welcome to the kill test
I will take your machete and deliver
some lethal blows on this ballistics
dummy
fun with your blade are you ready sir
yes sir
I hope my blade doesn't break I had a
lot of setbacks making this blade you
know I had to start over I hope it
doesn't come back to bite me in the buck
I'm saying a little prayer please don't
break please don't break please don't
break
foreign
here this is a very forward heavy blade
but that forward weight really Cuts deep
into this ballistics dummy overall sir
you will kill
that's worth it right there I go home
now all right blade Spitz this is the
kill test your boa Sunday's short swords
look deadly but can they kill to find
that out I will take your weapons and do
some killing slashes and blows on this
big carcass all right Justin your turn
are you ready let's get it done
[Music]
for a stop I really appreciate the
Damascus pattern that you have on here
it's very stunning to look at thank you
now the design you have thrust easily
through the carcass at the same time
creates a big wound Channel with every
thrust and extraction as I'm doing that
now it is a much lighter sword than your
competitors overall sir
it will kill thank you all right
gentlemen you know what time it is it's
time for the strength test the shield
chop
what I want to see on top of how durable
your blades are is there Effectiveness
against that Shield all right
everything is riding on these four
strikes I need my machete to hold
together I've got to make it through
this
all right gentlemen test the strength
and overall construction of your blade
I'll be chopping and stabbing into our
Shields over here
do your worst
if I was going to do my worst I'd just
slam it on the concrete I wouldn't do
that to you
[Applause]
all right Josh tips 100 that's great
handle is very comfortable as far as the
construction goes I think it's beautiful
I think your design and shape is
excellent good job awesome
forged in fire war of weapons